[BLANK_AUDIO]
Ugh, son of a SQL,
this milk is older than I am.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> [SOUND] Hello?
>> Hey, Kagure.
So I'm making a cake for the V3
launch party, and we're out of milk.
>> Milk?
Yeah, you can use mine.
>> Yeah, it's a bit old.
Any chance you're at the store?
>> No.
No, I'm not.
I have a debt to settle.
[MUSIC]
>> Okay.
Man, where am I going to get some milk?
[SOUND].
Hey J.P.
>> Hey Lila, how are preparations for
the V3 launch party going?
Do you need anything from
the store while I'm here?
>> Actually really great you called,
I could use milk.
>> Sure thing.
>> That makes me think.
Now that we're actually
storing user data,
we could do a lot of interesting
things with that information.
Like, I don't know,
show who's bought what.
>> Or
you could also show them who's shopping.
>> That all makes sense,
a lot of sense actually.
All right,
version 0.3 launch party canceled.
Back to coding.